Herr Reisner auch mit ihnen möchte ich
natürlich noch mal über diese Bilder aus
Belgorod sprechen die ja heute auf jeden
Fall Twitter beherrscht haben und heißt
diskutiert werden wir haben es eben
gesehen wir haben russische
Helikopter gesehen es hat geraucht was
ist denn ihr Stand der Informationen
oder was sind ihre Einschätzung was da
heute in Russland passiert ist
ja tatsächlich wird man es erst in einem
gewissen Abstand zu deiner Ereignissen
tatsächlich sagen können was hier
passiert ist was wir sehen ist natürlich
die Bilder aus den sozialen Netzwerken
von beiden Seiten und wir sehen auf der
einen Seite das offensichtlich in einem
räumlich begrenzten Ort mehr oder
weniger ist dazu gekommen ist dass die
russische Seite so sagt sie zumindest
Kräft isoliert hat über die Grenze
gekommen sind und dass sie hier kaum
Flugzeuge Hubschrauber aber auch Panzer
einsetzt und diese Bekämpfung zu können
dieses Ereignis hat uns natürlich wieder
vor Augen geführt dass der Krieg vor
allem auch im Krieg im Informationsraum
ist und das nun beide Seiten versuchen
diese Ereignisse in ihrem Sinne zu
deuten auf der einen Seite wissen wir
dass die Ukraine versucht da und auch
versucht hat in der letzten Monaten
unter anderem mit Drohnen aber auch mit
Sabotage Aktionen in Russland zu setzen
und auch den Krieg nach Russland zu
tragen wenn der Krieg wieder zur Zeit
immer nur in die Ukraine getragen und
auf der anderen Seite wissen wir das
russland versucht natürlich das für ihre
Propaganda auszunutzen sprich ja der
große vaterländische Krieg 2.0 der
angefert Russland direkt bezüglich der
Urheberschaft muss man glaube ich noch
vorsichtig sein denken Sie an die
Ereignisse die wir im kremlar hatten vor
kurzem mit den Drohnenangriffen wo auch
bis heute nicht klar ist der wer war es
beide Seiten können Interesse daran
haben die ukrainische Seite um zu zeigen
man kann Russland auch tief in im ersten
Treffen und die russische Seite
unmöglicherweise das narrativ der
Bevölkerung wie werden Angriffen
gegriffen entsprechend verstärken zu
können
ja danke erstmal für diese erste
Einschätzung ich werfe gerade mal einen
Blick in die Kommentare ob es schon
Fragen gibt wenn ihr da draußen Fragen
an Herrn Reisner habt dann schickt sie
uns gerne in den Chat oder per Mail an
die eingeblendete Adresse ich werfe mal
einen Blick rein und es gibt natürlich
viele Fragen zu dem Thema auch wenn viel
davon wie sie schon sagen gerade noch
spekulatives ich stelle trotzdem eine
Frage und wir gucken mal inwiefern die
beantwortet werden kann Daniel Wendler
auf Youtube fragt wäre es möglich dass
die Ukraine ein Stück Russland erobert
und um dann Land zum Tauschen zu haben
ist das ein realistisches Szenario
das ist das jetziger Sicht da kein
realistisches Szenario denn dazu brachte
die Ukraine signifikant Kräfte die
Ukraine hat zurzeit Kräfte
zusammengezogen für diese geplante
Offensive die sogenannten Brigaden der
Offensive 12 Stück an der Zahl von
zwischen dreieinhalb bis 5.000 Mann man
würde durch den Versuch quasi Teile
Russlands im Besitz zu nehmen diese
Kräfte quasi in einer Art und Weise
einsetzen wir sicher nicht dienlich ist
nämlich dem Zweck quasi das ukrainische
Territorium wieder von den russischen
besatzungsgruppen frei zu bekommen und
man würde natürlich Russland da in einer
Art und Weise angreifen wie es
möglicherweise bis jetzt nicht passiert
ist und Russland würde vielleicht dann
noch andere Maßnahmen setzen die wir
jetzt gar nicht voraussehen können und
da ist natürlich schon auch interessant
wenn man betrachtet die letzten Monate
dass gerade auf dem Oktober letzten
Jahres Russland war mit dieser
strategischen luftkampagne nach wie vor
die Ukraine sehr schwer treffen kann und
die Ukraine die Unterstützung des
Westens braucht ihr vor allem der
Flieger werden und dem entgegenhalten zu
können das heißt ich denke die Ukraine
wird da tun nichts vermeiden das zu tun
sondern wird versuchen ihre Kräfte zu
bündeln für diese bevorstehende
Offensive
ja und wahrscheinlich ist es für mehr
Gespräch dazu jetzt gerade auch einfach
noch zu früh das sind trotzdem mal erste
Einschätzung für euch zu diesen Bildern
die ihr heute bestimmt schon auf Social
Media gesehen habt wir wollen jetzt noch
mal einen Blick auf das bigger picture
werfen und auf die Frage ob der Westen
die Stärke der russischen Armee jetzt
lange unterschätzt hat und der Anlass
dafür ist eine Analyse des britischen
Think Tanks Rosi die dem russischen
Militär Lernfähigkeit bescheinigt und
auch sagt da werden gerade Panzer und
Luftwaffen geschont für einen späteren
Einsatz und sie erreichen sie sehen das
ja recht ähnlich wie diese Analyse
die russische Armee hat ja wir haben es
gerade schon gehört zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich große Teile von
bachmut eingenommen und einige waren
davon überrascht das heißt aber sie
wahrscheinlich nicht so oder
das herausforderte daran ist dass ich
auch immer wieder darauf hingewiesen hat
dass man die russische Armee nicht
unterschätzen soll das schade dass
meiner Sicht der Ukrainer mehr als es
ihnen hilft oder wenn wir quasi die
russische Armee meines Lächerliche
ziehen und nicht verstehen dass das auch
ein ganz gezielter Teil des Kampfes im
Informationsraum ist der von Ihnen
angesprochene russische Bericht ist
tatsächlich der vierte Bericht der zu
diesem Thema erscheint und auch die
anderen Berichte haben ein sehr
nüchternes Bild gezeichnet und haben
klar dargestellt dass er die russischen
Streitkräfte zwar schwerwiegende Fehler
machen aber sie immer wieder in der Lage
sind sich anzupassen und dass man sehr
gut erkennen kann ist dass immer dann
wenn die ukrainische Streitkräfte
beweglich waren sehr erfolgreich waren
aber wenn die russischen Streitkräfte es
geschafft haben den Ukraine einen
Stellungskrieg aufzuzwingen und das ist
mittlerweile das zweite Mal der Fall
dann können die russischen Streitkräfte
ihre großen Fähigkeiten auch spielen und
das ist der Einsatz von massiven
Waffensystemen und Raketenwerfern es ist
auch der Bereich der kampfführungen im
elektromagnetischen Feld also stören von
Drohnen und so weiter und so fort die
Bericht sagt z.B dass die Ukraine im
Monat ca 10.000 Drohnen verlieren durch
den Einsatz dieser Kampfmittel und es
zeigt dass er die Russen sehr wohl in
der Lage sind sich anzupassen und für
uns bedeutet das dass die Ukraine in
einer Art und Weise unterstützt werden
musste über das hinausgeht was er
bereits jetzt getan wird
ja und wenn wir jetzt über diese Analyse
sprechen wollen und sie auch diskutieren
wollen mit Euch da draußen
müssen wir natürlich noch ein bisschen
mehr wissen was da genau festgestellt
wurde und an welchen Stellschrauben
intern bei der russischen Armee gedreht
wurde und das hat Carsten heckes für uns
zusammengefasst
Bilder aus dem vergangenen Jahr ein
Ukrainer schleppt mit seinem Traktor
einen eroberten russischen Panzer ab
Sehnen wie diese und schwere Niederlagen
gegen die Ukraine lassen die russische
Armee lange Zeit schwach wirken manche
Experten gehen sogar von einer baldigen
Niederlage aus doch eine Studie des
unabhängigen Forschungsinstituts für
Sicherheitsfragen dem Royal United
Services Institute zeigt russland hat
sein Kriegsbeginn dazu gelernt
Panzer werden besser verborgen die
Artillerie wird beweglicher kann so
gezielter angreifen und sich besser vor
Gegenschlägen schützen und die in
effektive Luftwaffe bleibt am Boden
stattdessen setzt Moskau immer häufiger
kann die Katze Drohnen iranischer Bauart
ein
zusätzlich wird Russland in der
Verteidigung stärker setzt vermehrt auf
Familie und fällt Befestigungen auch die
Luftverteidigung hat ihre Effizienz
gesteigert immer häufiger gelingt es
sogar Heimat Raketen abzufangen doch
Werbebanden in der Moskauer Innenstadt
zeigen Russland fehlen motivierte
Soldaten die Moral an der Front laut
Studie Russlands größte Schwäche
ja Thema Moral das ist ja ein Thema was
die russische Armee schon lange
beschäftigt ist das auch ein Problem was
die ukrainische Armee mittlerweile
eingeholt hat gerade in so einer
Situation in der wir uns gerade befinden
Stichwort bachmut
ja vielleicht kommt es noch kurz
einordnen zu können ja um da zu Moral
eine entsprechende Aussage zu treffen
sie dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
russischen Streitkräfte mit einer für
das Land gemessenen geringen oder zu
geringen Anzahl an Soldaten einmal
marschiert sind diese knapp zwischen 50
und 200.000 Mann nach dem Shop des
abwehrfolges durch die Ukraine hat
Russland versucht sich anzupassen und
die Erstmaßnahme war durch das
einberufen von Reservisten neue Kräfte
heranzuführen die waren natürlich nicht
vergleichbar mit dem Beruf Soldaten und
haben natürlich eine geringere Moral
gehabt da und das bewirkt natürlich bis
heute nach trotzdem und da gibt es auch
die Aussage von
Kommandanten durch Streitkräfte in
Europa genau kaviole hat Russland
geschafft hat die Truppenstärke von 350
bis 400.000 Mann anzusteigen und es
steht im Raum dass jetzt der neue
Kontakt Nicki zu laufen das sind diese
ca 120.000 Soldaten die aus der
Wehrpflicht heraus was eine Vertrag
unterschrieben haben wo man also
annehmen kann weil sie ja freiwillig
kommen dass möglicherweise die Moral
wieder höher ist das ist ja vielleicht
noch zum Verständnis auf der
ukrainischen Seite sehen wir natürlich
ganz eindeutig der Kampf zu Befreiung
des eigenen Landes der also hier sehr
anspornend wirkt wir haben die Erfolge
von Kiew zum Beispiel Erfolge von haggiv
oder Person das hat natürlich sehr viel
bewirkt aber das Problem ist natürlich
auch die Städte Abnutzung und wir haben
wenn es mehr erlaubt ist durchaus einen
Vergleich mit dem Ersten Weltkrieg und
nämlich mit dem Jahr 1915 wo also
nachdem die Elite gefallen ist im Jahr
1914 bis Anfang 15 es dazu gekommen ist
dass der Krieg vor man kriegt der
Reservisten geworden ist das heißt auf
beiden Seiten sind sich die 14-Jährige
40-jährigen Familienväter gegenüber
gestanden und das ist natürlich auch im
Falle der Ukraine so dass es auch hier
die Moral Scheins nachlässt aber man
natürlich versucht die entgegen zu
halten und die Frage ist natürlich auf
lange Sicht wie wird sich das Ausgehen
als auf der einen Seite 145 Millionen
Volk nämlich Russland das gegen 35
Millionen Volk wenn man die geflüchteten
weggerechnet kämpft da ist die Moral
zwar auf Druck in diesem Seite enorm
höher und auf der russischen scheinen
sich viele andere Wissen zu fragen warum
aber die schiere Masse und es nicht
bereit sein also einzusehen auf
russische Seite das ist keinen Sinn
macht zeigt natürlich dass dieser Krieg
möglicherweise noch lange dauert und
dass er noch viele Opfer fordern wird
ja Stichwort Masse und menschlicher
Verlust den wir da ja seit Ewigkeiten
seit über einem Jahr jetzt schon
beobachten hier fragt jemand aus der
Community wie viele russische Soldaten
müssen sterben oder in Gefangenschaft
sein bis Russland zurückrudert hat man
da schon mal irgendwas aus dem Kreml
vernommen wo gesagt wurde da ist
vielleicht irgendwo ein Schlussstrich zu
ziehen
nein hier gibt es ja keinerlei Aussage
von der russischen Seite wenn man die
sogenannte russische strategische Kultur
betrachtet so ist es so dass in Zeiten
der Krise das Volk enger zum terranen
steht und sich von tiranen erwartet dass
er es durch die Krise führt im
Wesentlichen es gibt zu den Verlusten
eine aus meiner Sicht der zitierbare
Angabe das ist die Aussage von
us-generalstoff-markt Miele der damals
nach dem Erfolg der Ukraine bei Person
gesagt hat dass die russische Seite
100.000 Mal an Tod und Verwöhnung
erlitten hat und auch die ukrainische
Seite ca 100000 mal am Boden
Verwunderung erlitten hat er hat damals
angedeutet dass möglicherweise der
Siegburger Person für Verhandlung
genutzt werden sollte dem man nichts der
Fall der Punkt ist das so lange Russland
bereit ist der neue Soldaten an die
Frauen zu schicken solange diese quasi
gegen die ukrainischen Soldaten kämpfen
solange kann man nicht davon ausgehen
dass Russland in die Knie geht und sich
möglicherweise zurückzieht und das ist
das Dilemma auch in der jetzigen
Situation dass die Ukraine immer wieder
neu gezwungen ist neuverbände
aufzustellen diese dann in den Einzug
schicken muss und darum auch die große
Hoffnung dass diese offensiv jetzt
durchschlägt und möglicherweise einen
einen entscheidenden Erfolg erzwingt der
die Russen dann zumindest zum einsehen
bringt oder auch nicht das ist die große
Frage die ihnen die Historiker
beantworten werden in ein paar Jahren
aber jetzt zurzeit können wir das so
nicht voraussehen
lassen wir uns noch mal auf die
Stichpunkte gucken die da gerade in dem
erklärstück angesprochen wurden wir
haben gehört russische Panzer seien
nicht mehr so sichtbar die russische
Artillerie habe sich verbessert und die
Befehlskette in der russischen Armee
sein nicht mehr so hierarchisch wie Sie
das einmal war kann man denn irgendwie
sagen was da ganz konkret der Auslöser
war seit wann sich diese Veränderung in
der russischen Armee abzeichnen
also der Punkt ist natürlich im
Wesentlichen dass wir wenn man die
beiden Streitkräfte vergleichen klar
sagen müssen dass die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte unter anderem auch durch
die Ausbildungen der letzten acht Jahren
durch ein Auto starten es geschafft hat
vor allem im Sinne der Auftragstaktik zu
handeln das heißt das Verstehen dessen
was das übergeordnete Kommando will und
das umsetzen was sie nach freien ist
Wesentlichen auf der anderen Seite die
russische Armee die sehr zentralistisch
agiert wo sie nicht gewollt ist dass
jemand selbstständig Entscheidungen
trifft möglicherweise unmittelbar in der
Situation das Gefecht aber nicht quasi
wenn es darum geht größere Verbände zu
führen die Verluste der Russen waren und
sind enorm und das hat natürlich dazu
geführt dass vor allem die Unterführer
aber auch quasi die Vorgesetzten
Kompanie Bataillon erzwungenermaßen
begonnen haben sich anzupassen und viele
Taktiken hervorgeholt haben die wir
eigentlich zum Teil aus der Zeit des
Zweiten Weltkrieges kennen also z.B das
Bilden von kleinen sturmgruppen die dann
was im Häuserkampf Vorgehen der Einsatz
von Artillerie die rasche Abstimmung des
heranholen des Feuers auf
unterschiedliche Ebene aber auch zum
Beispiel moderne Waffensysteme das
Problem ist dass die Ukraine ein großes
hat beim Einsatz von russischen
kamikazedonen das sind sogenannte
landsitz-drohnen die täglich sind wir
ein zwei Videos artilleriesysteme zu
stören oder auch radiosysteme und daran
erkennt man das die Russen sehr wohl in
der Lage sind sich anzupassen verjähren
ist die Situation auch im sogenannten
elektromagnetischen Feld also da wo es
um stören geht zum Beispiel wo man auch
aus dem Bericht herausnehmen kann dass
die Kommunikation der Ukrainer das
vorhandene motorola-netz offensichtlich
von der großen gehackt worden ist bzw
auch der Umstand dass gerade diese
Drohnen die ganz wichtig sind für die
ukrainische Aufklärung offensichtlich
geschämt werden das ist also das
englische englische Wort für stören und
dazu es kommt dass diese abstürzen und
das sieht man natürlich dass die Russen
zwar Fehler machen aber sich anpassen
und nach dieser Zeit des Krieges
offensichtlich in der Lage sind in
dieser stationären Einsatzführung
Erfolge zu haben das heißt aber noch
nicht dass sie auch in der Lage sind
jetzt wieder operative Maßnahmen
durchzuführen also möglicherweise sind
Offensive zu gehen das sieht man zurzeit
noch nicht
ja dieser Bericht sagt ja unter einem
unter anderem auch einen sehr sehr
starker Teil der russischen Armee sein
eben die russischen Ingenieure die eben
Schutzwälle etc bauen da haben wir hier
bei ZDF heute live auch schon darüber
berichtet über z.B Drachenzähne was ist
die Qualität dieser russischen
Ingenieure was gelingt da gut
also man weiß natürlich aufgrund der
vorlagenden aufklärungsbilder sehr genau
wie diese russischen Stellungen sich
darstellen man sieht dass sie quasi den
Grundsätzen der militärischen
Verteidigungsstellungen entsprechen es
gibt also hier Panzergräben die also die
Panzer zwingen sollen zu halten um sie
dann in das Feuer von Panzer per
Lenkwaffen zum Beispiel zu bringen es
gibt diese von Ihnen angesprochenen
Drachenzähne die es auch den Erfolg des
Helmen
es gibt Minenfelder wo man also versucht
quasi durch eine Kanalisierung die
angreifen Teile hinein zu locken es gibt
Bunkerstellungen die verbunker sind mit
schweren Waffen und so weiter und so
fort ja die Geschichte hat gezeigt dass
derartige Verteidigungslinien oft groß
angekündigt worden sind aber oft nicht
durchgehalten haben denken Sie an die
maschinellinie oder denken Sie auch an
den Atlantik weil die metaxislinien
Griechenland und viele andere Beispiele
der Punkt ist aber dass die Ukraine
natürlich eine Herausforderung hat und
das ist die nicht vorhandene eigene
Luftwaffe darum auch die Forderung nach
den 16 Kampfflugzeugen denn natürlich
mit einer eigenen Luftwaffe wäre es
möglich diese Stellungen vorzubereiten
also gezielt Stützpunkte anzugreifen
und die Voraussetzungen zu schaffen für
einen vormarsteigenden Kräfte das Weite
ist natürlich das vorhandene
pioniergerät man braucht also hier
Minenräumen Panzer man braucht
rückenlegebands um diese Stellungen zu
überwinden und darum ist der Moment der
Überraschung und Täuschung so wichtig
damit die Ukraine schafft diese
Stellungen zu durchbrechen das kann
gelingen kann aber auch scheitern auch
hier wird man sehen wie die nächsten
Wochen und Monate sich dann darstellen
und ob es gelingt dann entscheidender
Stelle einen Durchbruch zu erzielen der
möglicherweise dann einen Erfolg für die
Ukraine möglich macht so wie das bei
Personen gesehen ist bei Haki oder zuvor
ja Thema Luftwaffen bzw fehlende
Luftwaffen der Ukraine zwei Fragen dazu
jetzt hat er am Wochenende haben die USA
und andere Nato-Partner diese F 16 Jets
zugesagt von denen sie gesprochen haben
wie läuft das denn jetzt ab könnten
überhaupt noch schnell genug in die
Ukraine kommen um in dieser früher als
Offensive wo niemand so richtig weiß hat
sie schon begonnen in leichten Teilen
wird sie noch stärker wirklich loslegen
können diese erst 16 jetzt da überhaupt
einen impact haben
hier lassen sie uns ganz kurz auf die
Offensive eingehen eine offensives
militärischer Sicht besteht immer aus
drei Phasen die erste Phase ist die
sogenannte Vorbereitungsphase hier
versuchen sie den Gegner so zu schwächen
dass wenn sie dann angreifen und das ist
dann die entscheidende Phase die zweite
Phase sind entsprechend rasch
durchbrechen können um dann in einer
dritten Phase das gewonnene Gelände zu
halten und sich zu konsolidieren wir
sehen dass die erste Phase begonnen hat
die Ukraine versucht auch unter den
Einsatz von der weitreichenden Drohnen
Treibstoffe anzugreifen
Verkehrsknotenpunkte anzugreifen sie
versucht zu sontieren und zu schauen wo
in diesen russischen
Verteidigungsstellungen sind Lücken wo
sie quasi ansetzen können und sie
versuchen auch zum Teil fliegen Abwehr
nach vorne zu bringen in dessen Schutz
dann quasi die veranstalt Kräfte sich
bereitstellen können wenn es günstiger
scheint kann man von dieser ersten Phase
in die zweite kommen wenn es nicht
günstig erscheint kann man das natürlich
in die Länge ziehen das heißt die zweite
Phase kann auch möglicherweise erst in
ein paar Monaten passieren damit sie mir
jetzt bei der Frage der Kampfflugzeuge
Kampfflugzeuge sind natürlich ungleich
Komplex in der Ausbildung als z.B ein
Kampfpanzer der selbst auch eine
Herausforderung bereits darstellt und
man heißt dass es natürlich hier erstens
Piloten verwendet werden die also
bereits eine gewisse Vorausbildung haben
die zum Beispiel auf der Mic 29 geflogen
sind oder auf einer su24 aber trotzdem
die Technik ist natürlich ein gewaltiger
Unterschied das wäre so wie wenn sie aus
einem Lader Tiger quasi in einen Tesla
umsteigen sie müssen das eine Reihe von
Dingen hier berücksichtigen und bedienen
können und da ist die Expertenmeinung
das ist zwischen vier und sechs Monaten
braucht um ein gewisses
Ausbildungsniveau zu bekommen dann
können Sie die Maschine steuern können
Sie die Waffen einsetzen aber es geht da
dran auch darum im Verbund entsprechend
wirksam zu werden und Sie dürfen nicht
vergessen dass auf der anderen Seite die
russischen Piloten auch entsprechende
Erfahrung gesammelt haben und auch ein
ernst zu nehmen dagegen sein werden das
heißt die Frage wird jetzt Zeit für die
Ukraine wartet sie ab und auf diese neue
Fähigkeiten zurückzugreifen oder
riskiert sie die Offensive und der hofft
dass man sie dann die Kampfflugzeuge ist
auch möglich machen dann im weiteren
Folge vor allem eine Abwehrkampf
weiterzuführen gegen Russland aber vor
allem auch die Tiefe des Landes
Stichwort
aufgrund dieser strategischen
luftkompete Russen entsprechen D der
sichern zu können
ja und wenn wir schon mal bei der
Definition solche militärischen Begriffe
sind mit denen wir ja gerade fast
tagtäglich hantieren da gibt's noch eine
Frage aus der Community dazu und zwar
fragt ein User auf Youtube alle sprechen
von der Großoffensive auf der
ukrainischen Seite aber kann man ohne
Lufthoheit mit sehr kleiner schwacher
Luftwaffe überhaupt eine klassische
Großoffensive starten
gerade das ist das große Dilemma dass
ich hier natürlich stellt es gibt hier
ein sehr schönes Beispiel aus dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg denken Sie an die
Landung der Streitkräfte in der
Normandie diese Landung wurde in den
Wochen und Monaten ganz gezielt durch
die alliierte Luftwaffe vorbereitet man
hat also hier Brücken zerstört man hat
Verkehrsknotenpunkte angegriffen man hat
alles unternommen um zu verhindern dass
dann am tag der Landung die
bereitgestellten deutschen
Panzerdivisionen rasch nach vorne kommen
und dann quasi die angelernteten Kräfte
wieder ins Meer zurückwerfen und eine
ähnliche Situation haben wir hier wir
haben also klar die Absicht eine
offensive durchzuführen aber es fällt
dieses Element quasi der Einsatzführung
aus der Luft jetzt ist es so dass in der
modernen Kriegsführung durchaus durch
den Einsatz von präzisen Waffensystemen
man das kompensieren kann aber natürlich
ca 100 bis 150 Kampfflugzeugen mit
entsprechender Bewaffnung haben
natürlich einen ganz anderen Effekt als
einige wenige die immer wieder in der
Lage sind spektakulär zum Beispiel die
Storm einzusetzen so wie wir das in der
letzten Tagen zumindest sieben Mal
gesehen haben aber die Masse fehlt hier
so wichtig ist und beginnen Offensive
umrascht diesen überraschungs und
täuschungseffekt zu ziehen und schnell
durchzubrechen und das ist der Moment
die Ukraine hat also dieses Momentum am
Beginn und das muss sie nutzen in der
Absicht einen Art Domino oder
kaskadeneffekt zu ziehen wie das bei
haargift gelungen ist der dazu führt
dass quasi das russische
verteidigungsdis positiv zusammenbricht
und die Soldaten zurückfluten das wäre
genau der Effekt erzielen möchte und da
ist das natürlich so dass eine
funktionierende Luftwaffe für einen
wesentlichen Unterschied macht
ja lassen Sie uns vielleicht noch mal
bei der ukrainischen Armee bleiben hier
fragt jemand auf Youtube wie hoch waren
denn die ukrainischen Verluste in
bachmut also wir haben jetzt gehört so
steht es um die russische Armee sie
scheinbar besser ausgerüstet als gedacht
wie steht's jetzt aber nach dieser
langen Schlacht um bachmut um die
ukrainische Armee
ja diese Frage werden wir auch erst in
der Nachschau beantworten können
möglicherweise erst in ein paar Jahren
wenn er so alle Daten vorliegen die
einen Analyse zulassen sie sehen jetzt
natürlich das momentan der Kampf um die
Deutung so heute losgebrochen ist als
auf der einen Seite die Russen die sagen
wir haben paar gute eingenommen und
haben den Ukraine schwerste Verluste
dabei gebracht auf der anderen Seite die
Ukraine die sagt wir haben den Russen
schwerste Verluste gebracht und wir sind
die Gewinner und das haben die Russen
gewonnen aus dem Berg war
Quadratkilometer Land im Wesentlichen ja
man weiß dass beide Seiten massiver
Kräfte herangeführt haben es war so dass
nach den offensiven behaarte von Person
bereits letztes Jahr auch ein möglicher
Vorstoß aus dem raumschi Richtung Süden
geplant war aufgrund des Abzugs der
russischen drucken bei Person ich nenne
das das russische den Kirchen weiß
möglich diese Kräfte unter anderem im
Park einzusetzen Luft an die Kräfte und
auch Wagner und du die Ukraine war
gefordert diesen starken Druck
entgegenzuhalten und hatte so begonnen
immer wieder ein paar Millionen also 4
500 Soldaten nach den anderen Nachbar
Mut zu verlegen wo sie diesen russischen
Druck versucht haben entgegen zu halten
das heißt es hätte vielleicht
möglicherweise schon früher eine
offensive gegeben wenn der Druck der
Russen bei Bank Mut nicht so stark
geworden ist ja fakt ist aber dass das
Ziel dass die Russen sich gesetzt haben
nämlich den kompletten Oblast und jetzt
einzunehmen bei weitem noch nicht
erfüllt ist sie haben jetzt zwar in der
zweiten Verteidigungslinie die Stadtpark
Mut eine wichtigen Stützpunkt
eingenommen aber dahinter folgen die
ersten Verteidigungsstellungen bei
chassoff ja und eine noch stärker
ausgebaute Verteidigungsstellung immer
Raum westlich davon und das bedeutet
dass das Ziel dass die Russen sich
gesetzt haben noch in weiter Ferne liegt
und das ist es auch hier gilt Kilometer
für Kilometer vor zu marschieren und
wenn das in diesem Tempo weitergeht dann
ist die Frage ob die russische Armee in
der Art und Weise wie sich das
vorgenommen hat doch tatsächlich das
schaffen kann
lassen sie uns nochmal auf die Stadt
bachmut gucken über die haben jetzt viel
gesprochen mein Kollege tim hat auch
schon gesagt so richtig viel ist von der
Stadt eigentlich gar nicht mehr übrig
und hier fragt auch jemand aus der
Community was bringt das eigentlich das
Russland jetzt bachmut erobert hat wenn
von der Stadt nichts mehr übrig ist sie
haben ja auch gesagt es handelt sich
weiterhin weiterhin um einen strategisch
wichtigen Stützpunkt
genau da muss man verstehen dass
russische narrativ das ist hier in den
Tag gelegt wird die Russen sagen sie
führen eine Demilitarisierung der
Ukraine durch das heißt die Russen
argumentieren ihr vorgehen damit dass
sie die Ukraine zwingen immer wieder neu
Reserven und die Front zu bringen wo sie
dann durch den Einsatz dieser russischen
verheerendenwerfer zerstört werden das
Ergebnis sehen Sie dann auf den Bildern
das sind nicht nur Städte wie back Mut
sind auch Städte wie auf die FK es ist
Städte wie UKE da oder auch marienkammer
gerade die Bilder marien
vergleichbar quasi mit der Situationen
wie wir das aus dem ersten weltkinder
eine völlige waste Landschaft und da
hintergrund ist der dass die Russen was
ich hier versuchen im Stellungskrieg die
Fähigkeiten auszuspielen wo sie immer
noch den Ukrainern überlegen sind und
das ist dieser massive Einsatz von
Artillerie Systemen wo sie versuchen die
Ukraine abzunutzen und darum ist es so
wichtig für die Ukraine in die Offensive
zu kommen um aus diesem verheerenden
Stellungskrieg auszubrechen etwas was
wir genau gleich auch im ersten
weltkriegt haben damals war es unter
anderem auch die lung des Panzers die
dazu geführt hat dass man aus dieser
stationären Bewegung in eine
bewegungskriegsführung gekommen ist und
ähnliches sehen wir jetzt gerade auch an
der Situation von Mut auf die FK und
geht auch an anderen Orten im dompass
ja wir haben noch eine Frage aus der
Community die sich noch mal um das
Innenleben der russischen Armee kümmert
und zwar ist die Frage ist die Rhetorik
vom Wagner Anführer also von Herrn
prikosin schon einen Anzeichen für die
Schwierigkeiten die sie zum Beispiel in
bachmund haben diese Frage zielt
wahrscheinlich darauf ab dass
wagnerführer prigoshi angekündigt hat
dass er seine wagnertruppen aus der
Stadt zurückziehen wird
ja es gibt in der russischen
oder auch in der russischen Kultur des
Militär aus einem Begriff dann in sich
Maske rafka es ist der Begriff der steht
für Überraschung und Täuschung das ist
man versucht im Gegner etwas
vorzugaukeln in der Absicht ihn zu
täuschen und wenn man jetzt der Groschen
ansieht und dass es in den letzten
Wochen und Tagen immer wieder gesagt hat
so muss man feststellen dass
offensichtlich auch das hier angewandt
worden ist weil es war nicht so dass er
die Dinge die angekündigt hat er noch
umgesetzt hat im wesentlichen ja
interessant ist auch z.B lass uns zwar
gegen
Putin Wetter hat und Putin vor kurzem
Wagner gratuliert hat zu diesem Erfolg
das heißt abwarten was tatsächlich
passiert in den nächsten Tagen ob Wagner
was sie sich wirklich kennt sich
zurückzieht aber es ist eine Übergabe an
die russischen Streitkräfte kommt und
was die Rolle von Wagner ist sie dürfen
nicht vergessen wenn wir diesen Krieg
auch ein bisschen vergleichen mit einem
Spiel wie Risiko ohne dass jetzt quasi
ins Lächerliche zu ziehen aber nur eine
Idee dazu zu geben so wissen Sie ja dass
bei diesem Spiel ist darum geht
Soldatenfiguren in verschiedenen
Regionen zu platzieren und wir sehen
jetzt natürlich immer auf das was in der
Ukraine passiert aber wer hat das so
mitbekommen dass gerade auch Wagner
durchaus globalen Einfluss ausübt wie
zum Beispiel Afrika denn in der Zeit wo
quasi die Spielfiguren in der Ukraine
sich bewegt haben hat Russland es
geschafft durch Wagner Spielfiguren zu
platzieren in Mali zum Beispiel in
Burkina Faso und auch in Libyen und das
hat natürlich eine Bedeutung das heißt
man muss es auch hier diese globale
Rolle von Wagner entsprechend betonen
und die Herausforderung die sich dazu
für uns ergibt denn wenn es es Wagner
und damit russlandschaft z.B die Zahl
Zone zu kontrollieren dann hat es
natürlich einen unmittelbaren Einfluss
auf Europa Stichwort
Migrationsbewegungen und so weiter und
so fort
ja lassen Sie uns zum Abschluss
vielleicht noch mal zusammenfassen die
russische Armee scheint also besser
ausgestattet besser aufgestellt als
jetzt lange gedacht dazu die Situation
in bachmut was glauben Sie oder wie
schätzen Sie ein dass die ukrainische
Armee jetzt darauf reagieren wird was
wird sie vielleicht an ihrer Taktik an
ihrer Strategie ändern um darauf zu
reagieren
die ukrainische Armee hat es geschafft
trotzdem starken Drucks der Russen im
Park Mut ihre entscheidenden Reserven
die sie für die Offensive bereitgestellt
hat noch nicht einzusetzen wir können
das ganz gut daran erkennen dass wir in
diesen Aufnahmen noch aus den sozialen
Netzwerken der Kämpfe in bergmutters im
Norden und im Süden noch keine Fahrzeuge
sehen die quasi für diese Brigaden
Offensive bereitgestellt worden sind das
heißt die Ukraine hat sich nicht
verlocken lassen diese Kräfte quasi
entsprechend auszuspielen sondern sie
hat sie immer noch Gewalt verfügbar für
diese mögliche Offensive die Frage ist
natürlich wo und wann und welche Umfang
wird diese Offensive stattfinden das
wären in den nächsten Wochen erleben und
auch Erfolg wird davon abhängen ob es
den Ukraine gelingt mit Überraschung und
Täuschung entsprechend durchzustoßen was
wir mitnehmen müssen ist das ist
überhaupt nichts da hilft quasi die
Russen lächerlich zu machen deine schade
dass meiner Sicht der Ukraine mehr als
es ihr hilft natürlich hat die Ukraine
auch im Informationsraum ganz klar die
Absicht zu zeigen wie gut und überlegen
Sie auch handeln kann und dass sie den
Initiative zurückgeben kann aber sie
dürfen nicht vergessen dass die
russischen Streitkräfte einiges an
Potenzial verfügbar haben ich verweise
hier noch einmal immer auf die Aussagen
auch von hohen US-Militärs die auf das
Hinweisen general kariole habe ich schon
genannt aber auch general Mark Miele und
die zeigen dass es auch tatsächlich die
Russen noch einiges in der Hinterhand
haben das heißt wenn wir wollen dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnt dann muss
sie massiv unterstützt werden denn die
Situation wird nicht einfach vorbeigehen
wenn wir es so machen wie bis jetzt dass
man einfach immer ein bisschen was
liefert in der Hoffnung dass ich das
jetzt ausgeht und wir haben gesehen dass
einzelne Waffensysteme bis jetzt noch
nie das Züge an der Waage waren sondern
zusammen
schaut der unterschiedlichen Fähigkeiten
der möglicherweise eine Bewegung eine
tatsächliche Bewegung in diesem Konflikt
bringen falls nicht wird dieser
konflikter länger andauern
zum Thema Unterstützung da sind die USA
oder auch die anderen NATO Partner ja
über die Zeit schon der Ukraine immer
weiter entgegengekommen da gab es quasi
rote Linien die überschritten wurden
lange wurde gesagt es werden keine Kampf
statt geliefert jetzt werden Kampfjets
geliefert was müsste denn von westlicher
Unterstützer Seite passieren dass sie
sagen würden das ist eine angemessene
Unterstützung
dazu muss man jetzt auch diese
Waffenlieferungen weniger einordnen und
auch hier erzähle ich Ihnen nichts Neues
sondern dass wir das auch immer wieder
intensiv diskutiert auch in
amerikanischen Zirkeln oder auch in
verschiedenen sehr hochkarätig besetzten
Tageszeitungen der Punkt ist dass die
Amerikaner Versuchung wie in einem
Boxkampf die Russen dahingehend zu
besiegen dass sie nicht versuchen das
mit einem k.o zu erreichen sondern mit
einem Punkt besiegt das ist mal versucht
Runde für Runde für sich zu entscheiden
sie sehen also sehr gut am Schlachtfeld
wenn es quasi aus einer symmetrischen
Situationen eine asymmetrische kommt
also wenn Russland war sehr erfolgreich
hat dass die Ukraine das bekommen dass
es braucht um wieder eine symmetrische
Situation herzustellen aber leider auch
nicht mehr ich gebe Ihnen ein paar
Beispiele 20 heimersysteme wurden
geliefert die haben einen entscheidenden
Effekt im Sommer erzielt die Ukraine hat
50 bis 100 gefordert die haben sie nicht
bekommen denken Sie an diese
weitreichenden Raketen vom Camps mit 300
km Reichweite die Ukraine hat bekommen
Rakete mit einer Reichweite von 160 km
denken Sie daran an die Diskussion auch
hier hat die USA gesagt der Ball ist
jetzt Europa wenn die europäischen
Verbündeten F16 liefern wollen soll es
uns recht sein wir selber liefern
momentan keine F16 denken Sie auch an
den Umstand dass all diese
marschflugkörperpatronen ballistischen
Raketen Ziele treffen die Fliegen alle
mit dem russischen
Satellitennavigationssystem das könnte
man stören oder zerstören das wird aber
nicht gemacht und denken Sie auch an
diesen Abzug bei Personen wo plötzlich
über drei Brücken die unter dauerbeschuh
standen über Nacht 30.000 russische
Soldaten sich abziehen können das heißt
man sieht dass man versucht quasi den
Russen auf lange sich zu zeigen es macht
keinen Sinn die Ukraine bekommt immer
das was sie braucht aber auch auf der
anderen Seite versucht man das quasi
auch nicht zu erreichen und das ist
natürlich ein Thema denn es bedeutet
dass der Krieg länger dauert das
bedeutet dass die Ukraine immer wieder
gezwungen ist neue Kräfte aufzustellen
wenn sie mich jetzt fragen würden was
muss passieren damit die Ukraine einen
entscheidenden Erfolg hat durchsetzen
kann so ist es so dass man quasi alle
Komponenten die das moderne Streitkräfte
brauchen abbilden muss und dazu gehört
zum Beispiel auch der Umstand dass die
Ukraine Flugzeuge brauchte eine
funktionierende Luftwaffe nicht nur um
den eigenen Luftraum zu sichern und die
Tiefe des Landes denken Sie an die
laufenden Angriffe der strategischen
Ebene von russischer Seite sondern um
auch die besetzen Gebiete zurück zu
Ohren und um das geht es im Wesentlichen
die Ukraine möchte die von Russland
besetzen Gebiete zurückerobern in der
Grenze wie es von Russland auch in der
letzten Jahren immer wieder bestätigt
worden ist bis zu dem Angriff der
eigentlich schon 2014 passiert ist und
nicht da 2022 wie wir auf den Eindruck
haben Tag des 43 Tage so